on se dise la mode était la culture où
aucun mouvement militant venu tout droit
des etats-unis qui a pour but de mettre
en lumière systématiquement toutes les
minorités et tous les combats militants
aujourd'hui c'est superman qui se
convertit à son tour au mouvement en
devenant conscient des enjeux
climatiques des injustices sociales mais
pas seulement car dans le dernier numéro
de la bande dessinée superman éditées
par dc comics le piste de clark kent
devenu lui-même nouveau superman tombe
amoureux d'un homme c'est le fils était
superman qui va faire son coming out il
s'agit donc de john keynes le fils de
clark kent il assume donc officiellement
sa bisexualité un véritable tournant
dans l'univers des super-héros dont
l'univers était jusque là exclusivement
hétérosexuelle est plutôt machiste une
décision qui a été saluée par de
nombreux fans mais qui pourtant ne fait
pas l'unanimité cet internaute français
créé par exemple on touche le fond quel
intérêt de faire un superman lgbt quel
est le rapport entre un super héros et
la sexualité pour certains ce changement
est une soumission au lobby lgbt et
passe pour de la démagogie dans le seul
but de faire parler alors superman
serait désormais bisexuels une bonne
chose
alors
que c'est une très bonne chose je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup de personnes qui sont
homophobes qui ont été élevés dans
l'ignorance et dans le mépris des
personnes homosexuelles ces bandes
dessinées elles sont consommées par
beaucoup d'enfants beaucoup
d'adolescents et c'est bien de
rencontrer un que ça existe on peut un
homme peut aimer un homme et un homme et
une femme peut aimer une femme est aussi
que ça n'entrave pas la virilité parce
que superman c'est censé être un symbole
de la virilité donc c'est très très bien
qu'il soit bisexuel dans ses valeurs
isabelle morini bosc mais c'est quoi la
question
isabelle moins au niveau 5 l'émission on
dirait qu'elle est en contrôle de ma
télécommande
[Musique]
un coin sujet
quoi la droite a mis quoi ils sont
déconnectés à la question vous demander
vos petits camarades merci géraldine on
mime alors évidemment j'ai le mauvais
rôle parce qu'effectivement il faut être
tolérant il faut être bienveillant et
c'est formidable de déconstruire les
schémas qu'on a comme ça et qui sont
détruits par les états unis mais en fait
juste en train de tomber dans le dans le
marketing us parce qu'en fait
qu'aujourd'hui le problème c'est que ben
c'est en fait c'est la jurisprudence
james bond alors james bond il ne peut
plus être amoureux parce que sinon elle
peut plus être un homme à femmes parce
que sinon mais du coup c'est pas bien
parce que c'est sexiste et que tout d'un
coup voilà il va d'une femme à l'autre
et du coup c'est on dit on déteste ça il
peut plus rouler avec une voiture qui
pollue parce que olala ça va pas c'est
mauvais pour la même du coup si on le
faisait drôle
ça devient chiant à mourir donc en fait
superman tombe à nouveau dans ce qui
chez moi vers de l'air en bas je m'en
fous mais c'est de la tour de démagogie
que de culture ont bloqué tout ça
sauf qu'une dictats des minorités qui ne
fait absolument pas alors justement et
on souffre aujourd'hui suffisamment
d'homophobie et je pense que ça ça n'a
rien changé oblige les jurés les accords
avec toi si c'était de superman dont il
s'agit il s'agit du fils de superman oui
on te déconstruit pas un héros qui
existe déjà c'est pas de la grande salle
culture pour le coup moi on n'efface
rien moi ce qui me gêne c'est quand on
est face quand on efface la belle au
bois dormant et qu'on ne faut pas
qu'elle se fera soit réveillé par un
prince charmant parce qu'une femme elle
peut être
là en l'occurrence qu'on ne conseille
pas on n'efface pas on ajoute donc moi
quand on ajoute semaine passée quand
c'est si on avait effacé hamon pourrait
poser un problème mathieu alors
géraldine stade heures mais là tu dis
vraiment amoureux alors généralement
quand on démarre la france parviendra
dienst
adorable heigl derrière c'est exactement
ce qu'il a fait d'être finie alors là tu
es une grosse bêtise c'est pas du
marketing c'est très simple en fait
c'est comme quand tu veux mettre à un
black à l'antenne ou à ou un maghrébin
ou que tu m'aies quelqu'un de bisexuelle
d'une série c'est juste pour dire à des
enfants qui sont jeunes et qu'ils n'ont
pas encore c'est juste on me représente
donc j'existe il s'est juste s'annonce
et justice pis la gamme un gamin de 10
ans qui va dire la série qui va dire je
suis perdu de ma sexualité ah bah tiens
le fils de superman peut-être il est gay
donc je suis normal il est aussi ont
donc c'est juste honteux représente pour
te montrer que ce que tu es est normal
dans ta représentation le fils de
superman symbole homosexuels parce qu'il
est musclé me faut il a une bonne tu vas
où le dessus on s'en fout il se
réchauffe ça changera rien c'est pour
dire aux gamins éventuellement si tu
préfère les garçons ou les filles c'est
pas grave tétouan fpt qu'avant on disait
quand tu es un super héros thème
forcément les femmes c'est ça ce que ça
veut dire qu'ils arrêtent de nous et
intellectualiser c'est toi qui as qui
intellectualise parce que c'est toi qui
as une mauvais l'argumentation parce
qu'avec village qui disent exactement le
contraire selon dieu quelle horreur
c'est mauvais mais sexuelle il m'aidait
père exigé jarry bien merci mais qui dit
n'importe quoi rien de ce que j'ai dit
sur vidal en un mot j'ai dis juste pour
la première fois qu'on montre un
homosexuel à l'antenne on le grime entre
guillemets avec une perruque et une robe
en femme ce qui fait en fait on a
l'impression que tf1 mais du coup un
homme et une femme à l'antenne et qu'on
a nous en fait ça n'a rien à voir ça n'a
rien à voir prends je te souhaite que
des enfants est une sexualité
parfaitement à 0 pour qu'il n'ait pas de
souci parce que franchement tu
m'inquiètes quand tu dis ça non c'est un
non sens mais non mais non
je suis entièrement d'accord ça m'aurait
étonné car
[Rires]
dès l'entamé
[Applaudissements]
djamel alesi madame rhein
trophy je me doute nettement et ça ne me
choque en rien en revanche aucun côté
démago réel talent et on ratisse sur
tous les marchés match entièrement
d'accord avec vous et marketing
opposants sont à ceux qui ont dix quinze
ans qu'ils vont lire une bd qui sont
perdus dans la sexualité junte est au
plus bas si l'on pensé d'enfantement
enfin dans s'il est pas un comic
soixante dix ans comme âge dit non
spie à la dictée de la décroissance et
pour moi c'est bien pensé à ça les
démagos parce qu'il ya plein de choses
qui sont faites il ya plein d'autres
choses à faire et on n'est pas obligé de
se forcer à faire des choses comme ça
justement moi je trouve hypocritement
pour faire parler ou pour faire du buzz
vous en tant que telle fusion on verra
ce que vous n'êtes
pas vie sexuelle mais ça me dérangerait
pas mais c'est grave ce que j'entends
quand même pas ce que tu veux on n'a pas
l'aura il ya 40% d'augmentation
d'agressions homophobes chaque année des
gens qui disent c'est du marketing tous
apprécié de tous et pour éduquer les
gens c'est pour leur dire justement
c'est pour dire aux gens à la fois aux
enfants qu'ils sont homosexuels et aux
gens peut-être aussi que sont homophobes
que non être homosexuel c'est normal
c'est juste leur dire ça et bien sûr à
rentrer dans ta tête tu rajoutes et non
mais t'as raison mathieu mais c'est un
truc beaucoup plus beaucoup plus profond
c'est la culture c'est l'éducation c'est
pas une bd de sur leur malheur elle va
alors on fait rien je sais quand je
t'entends j'entends les gens qui disent
bas c'est comme les [ __ ] égal quand
ils font ça finalement ils font ça pour
eux et pas pour des cons fait quelque
chose s'est aussi plié du marketing
derrière mais c'est bien de le faire
mais ça ne me dérangerait mais je pense
que tu es naïf et je pense que c'est pas
ça qui va déconstruire les problèmes et
qui va traiter les problèmes
si je pense pas que ça va aider à mieux
reposés à géraldine ah non mais je la
vole l'éducation guillaume gentil non
mais c'est vrai que notre génération et
les générations d'avant on a été levée
en nous disant voilà les filles jouent à
la poupée un garçon ne peut pas jouer à
la poupée et c'est bien il faut pas dire
est qu'il faut être à tout prix
homosexuel ou pas mais c'est bien de
montrer qu'il ya d'autres alternatives
et que c'est pas grave des mains garçons
quand on est un garçon qui a maintenant
des mines fille en fait non quand on est
noir
non avoir peur c'est pas une maladie
et à miner gers et mafate si on est
méfiant des bénéfices on aime les
garçons n'avaient rien au monde ce
dessin qui a plein de petits garçons qui
vont donner un homosexuel absolue jamais
et derrière avec des garçons qui se
sentent homosexuels à s'assumer d'avant
mais aussi peut pas d'animosité
je suis sa poche en doudou qu'est-ce qui
se passe justement c'est en fait c'est
la nouvelle génération de superman est
aujourd'hui dans la nouvelle génération
les jeunes filles et les jeunes garçons
se tâte de plus en plus tôt sur leur
sexualité avant il se pose même pas la
question bisexuelles ou homosexuelles et
ben on était dans un
jour le baiser - quoiqu'il en soit
aujourd'hui ça se démocratise et moi je
trouve ça super bien qu'on n'a pas qu'on
n'ait pas touché à l'ancienne génération
de superman est en revanche la nouvelle
génération propose autre chose parce que
c'est dans l'air du temps rend compte
que sans l'aide à mon époque à moi
c'était mal c'était mal de 31 mois la
première fois que j'ai fait ça j'étais
gamin la preuve après j'ai pleuré mais
j'ai pleuré juste parce que je m'étais
dit c'est mal ce que j'ai fait je suis
le diable c'est pas bien c'est pas bien
on avait tellement rentrer ça dans la
tête si un petit à l'école on avait dit
où il y avait eu des bd on m'a montré
que ce que je suis c'est pas mal mais
comme personne n'en parlait hier
internet tient pas instagram et qu'on
t'avait dit c'est mal c'est comme vendre
en pension je vois ce que je veux dire
c'est important tout ça quand même
arrêté dans du marketing partout il ya
des gamins qui souffrent c'est fou que
j'ai du mal à croire autant sur mamy bon
je mets toi
j'aime avec cette espèce de processeurs
diabolisation tout le temps non mais tu
es toujours un peu que toujours un peu
contre tous mammites est toujours apte
et contre tout va en croit pas qu'elle
n'est pas contre toi dans le
sélectionner il s'intéresse aux garçons
mais j'ai dit et alors je m'en fous
quand on s'intéresse aux garçons
allaient pas qu'on me disait ton fils
intérêts sont guère forêt est alors
ouais et alors ça ne m'a posé aucun
problème ça ne manqueront toujours cas
alors tu m'emmènes c'est pas toi seront
opposés seat 11 fixe éventuellement ses
attentes et un éventuellement ben oui
mais bon tu es toujours un petit peu
contre tout est toujours un peu trop tôt
les jours un peu border
non
vraiment pas de famine
je t'aime d'hommes en tout cas
maintenant je ne demande qu'à croire et
j'espère que c'est willy et je ne le
crois pas du tout quand elle va être
plus par mes gamins ça va permettre à
ceux qui sont violents aujourd'hui
qu'ils ont des sortes de process
homophobie qui vont qui vont tabasser
les les homos alors disons que c'est
laid sale [ __ ] je pense je pense j'ai le
geste je pense pas que ça va fonctionner
ils prétendent pas tout résoudre mais
n'atteint géraldine radis tout résoudre
c'est un premier pas et c'est tout si
tout le monde faisait un premier pas des
gens en avant serait ce serait mieux que
de dire ben non ça sert à rien non ça
sert à rien parce que nous ça sert à
rien ne se passera rien si rien ne
change rien ne change c'est pas de moi
qu'est ce qui
n'a rien écouté avec le nom mais je les
plus bavards alors castaldi par juste et
c'est vrai c'est de lui qu'il s'agit a
débuté pour le coup dont le coût donc
dans cette bd
moi je vais plus me mettre à pleurer un
jour
pour le coup c'est pas tellement que sa
réforme les gens qui pensent mal c'est
que les gens qui ce qui ne va pas se
projeter les petits garçons pour le coup
c'est un signal extrêmement fort segment
pour ça après effectivement que ce
marketing certainement mais c'est pour
les enfants qui se posent des questions
c'est évidemment une aide très important
ce qui se passe dans les pays
scandinaves c'est à dire qu'on empêche
gars sont brimés foot et on demande aux
petites filles de jouer au foot et crier
parce que les fanas de lullier pour
pourrait prendre le contrepoint des
gammes sont les garçons ça doit venir
souper ça doit se passer les liens avec
de la crème oui moi j'ai pas envie de ce
système moi j'ai envie que les garçons
soient des garçons et si vous aime les
garçons mais il aime les garçons et les
filles soient les chicots ciel zenawi
c'est un garçon a pas envie d'être un
garçon qu'est ce que tu vas faire
géraldine parce que si tu écoutes la
télé va être compliqué car c'est pas toi
qui décide de tout ça n'est qu'une
finale a pas deux garçons et une fille
mais c'est de la folie c'est ta fille
veut pas être une pige à décines mafia
pas envie d'être une fille ne sera pas
une ficelle envie d'aimer les chiens
elle aimera les filles bon alors là ce
genre de discours ça va pas aider non
mais ce que veut dire ce que vous dire
je dîne non mais ce que veut dire
géraldine c'est que il faut que
maintenant on substitue une dictature à
une
qu'elle veut dire en plein vol à quel
moment il est bisexuelle il embrassa
garçons c'est pas une bd porno en fait
dire à quel moment à quel moment on
entraîne dire qu'on rend compte qu'on
passe d'un extrême à un autre superbe
c'est notre vie des autres mais dès
qu'il arrive et là il a aussi des super
pouvoirs des bonbons pour voit très vite
d'ailleurs oui et géraldine même si je
suis pas d'accord avec elle mais c'est
vrai que c'est vrai que parfois au nom
de l' bien pensants sous mon nom de 2
voilà deux du parti du bien on veut
effacer des données de l'histoire on
veut effacer et on veut vraiment rentrer
dans le crâne des gens en leur disant
voilà la nouvelle façon de penser que la
raison c'est superman était devenu
bisexuelle et pour ses palaces et son
c'est pour ça c'est que ce que j'ai dit
a exactement à voir si vraiment tu veux
redire là dessus ouais c'est peut-être
moi excusez moi
[Rires]
c'est le cocktail d'entre ce qu'a dit
mathieu et guillaume c'est super on
appelle ça un truc
c'est vrai que c'est pas dit oui car
c'est vrai que c'est d'abord c'est la
bisexualité ensuite c'est son fils alors
peut-être c'est pour amener plus tard
mais ça me dérange pas c'est pas une bd
porno comme il a dit c'est peut-être un
extrait s'ils en font un film ce sera
peut-être 30 secondes même pas 20
secondes dans le film on va pas se
prendre la tête pour dix ans mais
certainement réagir oui mais ça fait
réagir mais moi ça me dérange pas plus
surtout que là où tu as raison c'est que
c'est peut-être aussi le prémice
peut-être d'un film peut-être d'un
système bien sûr mais j'en sais rien ou
peut-être parce que là un comice
effectivement c'est lui par les comités
sûr mais c'est vrai mais c'est vrai mais
je suis c'est pas un jeu sur qu'est ce
qu'on pensait peut-être qu'ils vont
refaire rox et rouky gay
mais c'est vrai bâtiment robin il se
tapait batman on le sait maintenant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]